so as a start-up when you want to
implement an incentive plan into your
marketing plan what do you need to do so
first of all like everything it has to
make sense your offering should be part
of your product which means that your
offering should make sense to you and
you need to encourage something that you
want your users to do you want the
offering to be precise by your users is
something that wolf money it doesn't
have to be money it can also be virtual
coins let's say that I'm promoting a
virtual game and if you're going to
invite your friends I'm going to give
you 50 coins okay I don't care about it
but my users care about it and they will
eventually hopefully pay for it so they
think this is a good thing so a few
examples about how to create great
promotional plans first of all paper
they probably created the first and most
famous promotional plans for startups
they basically paid their users to open
an account and invite someone else
thinking the in the top it was if you're
opening an account you get 10 bucks into
your account do whatever you want with
it if you're inviting someone else
you're getting 10 bucks and he's getting
10 bucks and that helps them to grow to
about 100 million users in a very fast
way they obviously didn't pay so much
money for all of for so many people they
they reduced it there are gradually five
bucks to one buck eventually to nothing
but that really helped them go
significantly another example that
people may know even better is the draw
box example they gave a lot of storage
to the users who invite other people so
you could get a free account basically
if up to 2012 gigs of free storage room
back in the day back in the day for the
three years ago four years ago that was
a lot to get today I have liked to Tara
and I paying 10 bucks but that was huge
and people was competing each other who
will get to their friends faster you
know to invite them and and make sure
that they will accept the in accept the
invitation and both examples the paper
and draw box makes perfect sense paper
it's all about the money you're getting
money in your account you can do
whatever you want with it and you can
use it to buy on eBay for example that
was the best
source of golf back in today and for
dropbox with a storage company you're
getting free storage invite your friends
that help them go to so many users and
and people are still trying to imitate
those those promotional plans
another example is Zynga when you're
inviting your friends you're getting
virtual currency for specific games that
they are promoting not only Zynga
obviously everybody who creates games
that has some kind of virtual currency
in it lets you do that and by earning
that virtual currency by earning those
things that you that you want in order
to proceed in your games they can
encourage this behavior
another example is lift lift is
competing with uber in many geographies
throughout the US for the world and lyft
wants to get more market share how can
they do that one of the one of the
strategies is to pay you to ride with
them so let's say I want to get from
point A to point B in Manhattan and this
is a ride it will cost me with uber 20
bucks with a yellow cab 15 bucks lyft
will give you money to ride with them so
it will cost you 5 bucks or 6 bucks in
this way they can encourage the behavior
that they want to encourage that forming
a habit of you associating lift with
with taking a cab by encouraging you and
giving you money to use them one major
thing that you need to be very cautious
about when you're doing incentive
problem it's making sure that your
lifetime value your LTV is higher than
your customer acquisition cost
yo CAC a lot of companies tend to
exaggerate with acquiring users focusing
on growth which is obviously the most
important thing for an early-stage
startup but as you go as you became more
and more successful people take
advantage of that the math doesn't make
sense anymore
it's it was working for PayPal but as
they're going more and more users you
don't want to do it anymore cause you
want to encourage them to actually pay
for that they do you
want to make them dependent on your
specific dynamics and Mechanics for for
earning virtual currency that can be
something very dangerous for a start-up
to be dependent on the incentive plan
and not focusing on keeping the users
engaged for the dynamics of the product
itself one more thing is that incentives
can only enhance the quality of your
product it will not replace anything so
if your product is great the thing that
you're doing with incentives is
encourage what you hope that your users
will be doing that's the final push
that's not the main thing you push them
to share you push them to activate you
push them to use it one time because you
know that once they use it for that one
time they'll be hooked but it won't
replace bad product it won't replace a
bad user acquisition strategy okay so
now that we've gone over the general
checklist for launch
let's explore ways to get your app
noticed